[Music]
for me I've always thought I'd rather be
missed
then somebody get tired of us chip and
Joanna Gaines on the record and
revealing of the real reason they've got
the cord on their HG TV show were you
surprised that people's reaction also
about that if the show's going away and
there's something has to be there has to
be a concrete reason there's so many
things even up leading up to it that I
had this skincare line and so I'm
leaving and it made it look like I was
doing my own thing and she didn't even
know about it you know that was just a
big rumor that our marriage was on the
rocks that I was pregnant it's funny
when you start hearing this stuff you're
like I guess people can just make stuff
up is this the end of you on TV can I
think we have no idea I think you know
we finish filming season five the first
week in November with five rebels left
and we are really loving every minute
that's let me just love our crew we've
loved the show but after that we're
really you know chip was thinking we
take some time Oh season five is gonna
come out we're gonna celebrate that like
you do where we literally every Tuesday
night we're at a television show a set
set at a friend's house was eatin
popcorn the whole nine yards and so
we'll go from from that to some number
of months off and then we'll catch our
breath and hopefully yeah no telling
what what looked at hand scores you know
we have a real life business on the
ground in Waco Texas we're opening a
restaurant January February there's a
lot of things we just gotta you know get
on the ground be a really big part of
that if these things are I'm still going
chip shares the secrets to creating the
couple's Empire in a new book capital
gains as you read this book what will
people learn about your journey
yeah that it wasn't easy you know it's
not a single easy thing about it lots of
late nights we put in tons and tons of
hard work even as we were bringing our
family along on this journey even that
was hard work I just wanted it to be
authentic and sincere and I know that
this journey for us has been just that
what is the one thing that you want to
go do like the thing you haven't been
able to do I want to sit somewhere it's
this way I want to sit and just
I just want to sit in this quiet place
and read capital gains first
[Music]
you